make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we're continuing on with our
avengers and new avengers and this one
is going to be
interesting right this one's going to be
interesting um the cool thing about this
is that we do
get basically a kind of full-on
explanation of what's going on after
this point right because one of the big
things that was happening here and this
is this is one of the the kind of
struggles that you get into
when it comes to hickman telling these
long-form stories because there's so
many complex plot threats going on
it can be difficult to keep track of it
all right and so you kind of find
yourself
in this situation where you almost kind
of feel free floating right like you're
not sure what's happening what's still
happening what's not happening anymore
and so what he really kind of does and
you consider his whole run to be in two
sections right this is kind of
the first section leading up to this is
all just one cohesive part after this
you go into the quote unquote time runs
out event and that's where everything
you know where everything really begins
to pop off right where you really get
into like the action-packed oh my god i
can't believe that happened part of the
story but up to this point you know what
this does is kind of clear us up and get
everything sorted out get everything
organized
and then we just go forward from there
now in the last video that we did we
talked about how the time zone had
reappeared in front of like iron man and
captain america and black widow thor
hyperion all these guys and basically
whisked them into the future right or at
least just kind of took them away where
they end up at is it 48 years in the
future
now when they get here uh they're
immediately set upon by what looked like
more or less avengers of sorts right and
and basically these guys are taken out
relatively fast and as soon as this this
ends then suddenly it's a realization
that's brought upon
by a combination of hyperion being able
to just kind of look at organic matter
you know the buildings around him things
like that as well as the power of star
brand and coming to the realization that
they're about 48 years into the future
right now for them for the most part
it's kind of a guess right but when when
you end up having hawkeye as well as
uh the future version of thor and the
future version of hyperion star brand
who all show up then it's kind of like
okay you know you're basically about 50
years in the future that's kind of the
explanation that's given now the funny
thing about this is you kind of have
this little bit of a standoff between
hawkeye uh his older self and his
younger self now as soon as they both
fire off arrows and they both hit the
others that's how they know that like
each one is legit right you know
future hawkeye knows and this is
actually his younger self and so on but
the funny thing is a future hawkeye kind
of knows what's going on right like he's
aware
of the idea that the time stone popped
up that it wished them 50 years into the
future and that what he's doing here is
kind of explaining a little bit to
captain america in so far that
uh there's a lot going on right there's
a lot of things that are that are taking
place
you're gonna go further into the future
than where you already are right now now
at that point of course he whispers
something into the ear of captain
america and we will find out here in a
little while
but he basically says like there were
two things that i was told to say right
the first one was what he said to
captain america and the second thing
when clint barton was like you know
when present day hawkeye was like what's
the thing you were supposed to say
future
hawkeye basically attacks tony stark and
says like this is for everybody who died
and all of us who live through it right
so whatever it is that happens
at least whatever it is that iron man
does is huge right it's a it's a pretty
significant thing because it seems to
bring pain and torment to everybody
around them but before
captain america can ask the question
like what was all that about or at least
before he can get an answer the time
stone pops up and it shattered pieces it
restructures itself
and begins to wish them away and when
hawkeyes ask the question what's going
to happen next his response is i don't
know this is as far as i made it i never
made it beyond this point right and so
ultimately you know hawkeye never really
gets
gets past this particular place and so
what it does is it picks back up in
fractured temporal space and all that
means is basically just kind of time
just sort of in the time stream is all
that is but hawkeye ends up falling off
right and that's why he never made it
past this point
because he never sees what goes on later
on now at this point we're 422 years
into the future and what ends up
happening here is the avengers basically
land
in the ultron future those of you guys
who don't know what that is marvel had a
line of comics called ultron forever and
it was a three issue mini series and we
covered it on the channel
in the comics explained channel so
you're welcome to check it out but the
idea here was that at some point in the
future
ultron basically shows up in kind of a
perfected form he essentially kills odin
steals the odin force conquers asgard
and then conquers earth and basically
starts merging humans and machines into
like a kind of cybernetic race
right now there are little pockets of
surviving humans but they're swiftly
being tracked down and either eliminated
or brought in
and replaced with these cybernetic
versions right but ultron's essentially
conquered everything and so it's kind of
nuts because you don't really get a
full-on i mean you kind of get a get an
explanation but you don't really get any
reconciliation
between the future age of ultron story
that we saw from i think it was bendis
who wrote it and uh and the
ultron forever storyline and i think
they're two separate features but i
don't remember off top my head but the
long and short of this is that when the
avengers show up they basically arrive
inside of this kind of stasis unit and
that's because their arrival was
expected their arrival was planned and
we'll talk about why their arrival was
planned here in a little while or at
least why the revival was expected here
in a little while
but you basically have these kind of you
know artificial intelligence avengers
who show up and basically kind of start
capturing these different guys now
the implication here is that this little
segment here with them showing up in the
ultron forever future
this seems to take place before the
events of the ultron forever story right
so
that kind of seems to be what's going on
here but you end up having captain
america who's basically taken by his
you know cybernetic counterpart who
actually hates his role right he hates
the idea that he's been programmed for
this purpose and that's kind of the way
this works right when a human is taken
and they're they're basically assigned
to an avengers role uh they're they're
basically programmed with all the
mannerisms right all the personalities
of those guys the only difference is
they know what they've been programmed
with so they don't really believe that
they're those individual characters
right so this you know
someone had a counterpart to captain
america doesn't actually believe he's
captain america it's just
the role he's been assigned but he hates
being that person which kind of
rightfully so captain america is okay
but at the end of the day he can't
really do anything right like if i were
going to be anybody i'd want to be like
blue marvel
or hyperion or like molecule man like
somebody cool right somebody interesting
but what ends up happening
is is you know this future version uh
basically ends up taking a kind of
uh you know bomb device more or less and
planting it in the eye of captain
america right basically planting it you
know inside of his own head and saying
like you're going to a place to where
this bomb is going to be needed right
this is going to be necessary it's not
for you in the here and now
the other part of this is that you have
black widow who of course has been taken
uh and she's communicating with her
cybernetic counterpart and this
cybernetic version basically says like
she wants to live
she wants to survive she doesn't want to
more or less perish whenever it is of
this you know timeline or universe or
what have you happens to end
that she wants to kind of continue
living on and that's an important thing
because what it shows is that these
cyberworks are not necessarily just
robots right they have feelings they
have emotions they have thoughts and
they have desires
the issue with this is that what this
cybernetic version of black widow wants
is actually very nefarious and we'll
find out why it matters here in a minute
but it's kind of an interesting thing
because this cyborg version of black
widow tells you know the
version of herself in the past who's
been transported with the time stone
tell the future man that his perception
of planet ultron is wrong that he
believes planet ultron is basically just
like a whole bunch of individual systems
operating as kind of a unified hold when
in reality it's the whole itself right
so instead of saying that you have like
a whole bunch of cybernetic organisms
acting independently and that they have
like kind of a shared mind a high of
intelligence that the reality is you've
got one guy running the whole show and
that's what ultron is now the future man
we'll talk about here in a second which
is kind of cool
what this version of black widow desires
is to be broken away from that that sort
of collective mind she performs she
desires to be independent she desires to
be separate because she knows that a
time will come it's just inevitable a
time will come when this ultron reality
or this you know ultron's reign over
earth will end
and she wants to ensure that when that
time comes and the ultron ai
is destroyed that she won't die with it
right they should be able to kind of
continue and live on and so on and so
forth and so as soon as this this bomb
is planted in the mind or in the brain
of captain america
the time stone reforms itself and then
him alongside black widow starbrand thor
and hyperion are basically whisked away
right back into fractured temporal space
but at that point
thor and hyperion fall away and that's
when we end up finding out that they've
been transported to 5 000 years into the
future now the the question that was
being asked here at the time was
where are they going right when hawkeye
fell off when when hyperion and thor
fell off where did they go right they
ended up right back in iron man's lap
and that's where iron man ended up right
where where the the gym in his hand
uh would basically tell him you know
when these incursions were happening
that would
also it would allow him to kind of move
through space and time right to move
from one
one universe to another we talked about
that earlier when we were talking about
the incursion wall right that you're
basically leaving one universe and going
into another one when you pass through
the incursion wall but because space and
time are effectively the same thing
if you can pass from one universe to
another then you can travel back and
forth through time it was never really
intended to be used for that purpose but
it was and that's where iron man was
sent to iron man's gym was basically
manipulated by the future version of
hawkeye and he was sent back to the
present day
and so that basically that really only
leaves here uh star brand black widow
and steve rogers and once they arrive
here they kind of end up on this this
kind of
garden of sorts with this colossal tree
growing in the middle of it and that's
what's kind of crazy is they try to
figure out what's happening right
there's a lot of kind of estimation kind
of guessing going on here the fact that
there's
long growth vegetation the tree is
absolutely massive because it takes so
long for trees to grow the response of
black widow which he thinks is around
you know a few hundred years from where
they were before captain america is
frustrated because he doesn't really
grasp the whole notion of time travel
right so he feels like he's just a fish
out of water but
at the end of the day you know the kind
of idea is this is some sort of a garden
right there's life growing here there's
plants so on and so forth and that's
when they're met by the future man
also known as franklin richards now for
those of you guys who are not familiar
with the work of jonathan hickman this
is the same future version of franklin
richards from hickman's fantastic four
right the one who resurrected galactus
from the dead and turned him into his
herald uh that's this version of
franklin richards right this guy is from
that far in the future right he's from
from that far along the timeline with
that being the case you kind of have uh
captain america who doesn't know who
this is right he doesn't know that it's
future franklin because remember captain
america has never met franklin richards
from the future he's only ever met
franklin when he was a little kid and so
the response is okay who is this guy
who's this guy walking out of nowhere
with this giant glowing orb on his chest
he kind of looks like iron man with long
hair
who is this guy and that's when he says
i'm franklin richards and of course he
kind of tells a little bit of a story to
black widow about how
uh you know she taught him when he was
younger to basically you know mix a hand
soap with a uh with a red or an orange
crayon to make like a low yield poison
just these little espionage tactics and
things like that and so it's kind of
like okay this is the actual guy right
this is actual you know the actual
franklin richards and that's when he
kind of starts commenting and saying
okay
you know like like what you guys have
been told up to this point is that
when you when you go forward into the
future uh the things will be different
right things can kind of fluctuate
things can kind of change
the response of franklin is no there are
no variables here
everything that happens happens the way
it's supposed to now i know it sounds
very cloak and dagger and it sounds very
ambiguous
but hickman does give us an explanation
here right before he kind of begins to
spill the beans on everything he takes
him on a little bit of a of a traveling
adventure right takes him out into space
and takes them around around saturn and
basically says that like out here
humans have moved beyond the planet
earth that where natasha's kind of
question here is well who owns all these
mining vehicles who are mining resources
from the the asteroid belt around saturn
you know is it like a company or like
what nation
you know managed to pull all this off
first the response of franklin is there
are no nation states right there there's
no china there's no united states
there's no brazil no none of that stuff
right there that all you have is just a
planet of human beings and he says that
at some point along the line humanity
reached that point that humanity got to
the point where it said these artificial
boundaries that we create between one
nation and another
creating like methods of currency
different things along those lines that
it was a handicap that was getting in
the way of our actual progress
it's very star trek-esque in that way
right for those of you guys who saw
first contact
there was an explanation there from
captain picard who basically told the
character of lily that humanity
abandoned uh money
by that the acquisition of wealth is no
longer the driving force in people's
lives that people simply just exist to
better themselves
and that's what this is right people
have just kind of moved beyond these
base
you know artificial means and it's just
humanity exploring and trying to become
the best version of itself that it
possibly can be the crazy thing is that
at this moment right now
there's around 30 billion people who
were living on the moon right now in
terms of the ability to live on the moon
it's not just limited to colonies right
keep in mind the moon has the blue area
which is an oxygen-rich section of the
moon
it's not colossal but most likely all
humanity managed to do was find a way to
harness that and then expand
it across the moon to basically make it
an oxygen-rich environment which really
begs the question how would that impact
the moon's orbit around the earth coming
book logic
[Laughter]
not something that needs to be worried
about but finally franklin gets around
to saying okay captain what do you want
to know right do you want to know
who like how the incursion started do
you want to know like what what led to
all this
right like who's behind all this these
universes crashing into each other and
the response to captain america is i
want to start with tony stark and i want
to know how to defeat them
i want to know how to stop them from
doing what they're doing trying to wipe
out and you know in cursive earths
different things like that and the
response of franklin is okay
that cannot be done he kind of gives us
a little bit of an explanation and says
it's important that you understand what
i'm going to tell you
so you can understand what i tell you
later and he says what you have here
in this this place that we're living in
in this future 5 000 years in the future
that there is no
i mean you do have earth to a degree but
this rogue planet this that red planet
that basically came crashing towards
earth that you guys managed to stop and
you guys managed to
basically phase in with the earth itself
that was sent by us
and that was sent because you needed it
right we're filling a loop like that
that rogue planet basically comes and
hits earth and it hits earth or at least
it comes towards earth because we sent
it there right we're kind of fulfilling
this sort of cause and effect loop but
more so than that and what's exceedingly
important here is this avengers machine
that was created by captain america and
tony stark
initially started with the idea of okay
tony stark wanted to distract captain
america and all them so that if they're
facing off against threats and captain
america's focusing on expanding the
avengers roster to make it you know
something that was worldwide that they
wouldn't be worrying about the
incursions or wouldn't be asking
questions like what's tony stark doing
or anything like that uh that it
actually kind of grew and
expanded and became its own kind of
thing and now what you have is called
avengers world it's this massive
planetary space station that serves
nothing more than the purpose of just
having avengers
protect the universe right the avengers
have moved beyond earth and they now
protect the entire universe in a wide
array of different capacities but that's
the important of it all because when
captain america kind of reiterates like
i want to know how to stop you know the
you know stop the new avengers from
doing what they're doing the response of
franklin is you can't there's no way for
you to stop them that what's going to
happen
is going to happen the time is not
something where like some event takes
place
in the future but if you go back in time
and you prevent that even from happening
then
you know everything's okay it doesn't
work that way everything kind of
branches off
so sure you could go back in time and
you could stop the illuminati you could
stop the the new avengers from doing
what they're doing but it's not going to
change anything you know your timeline
is going to continue on just like normal
you're just going to have an alternate
reality out there where the illuminati
were stopped but it wouldn't make any
difference because the multiverse is
still collapsing no matter what you do
there's nothing you can do to save the
day the multiverse
is going to die you know there are
universes out there where you went back
in time and you then you destroyed the
illuminati and your world still dies
right there's nothing you can do
to end this it's inevitable it's always
going to happen and so that's what makes
it kind of that's what makes it kind of
crazy it's because he asked him he's
like you know do you remember what it
was that hawkeye told you and the
response of captain america is yes i do
recall that and he basically says you
should ignore it but you won't
because your fate is your fate you you
make you are who you are because of the
choices that you've made the choice that
you made over the course of your life
led you here and understand captain
america this is not the first time
you've been here and where he's kind of
like
what like what are you talking about the
time gem pops up and whisks them away
the time gym basically yanks them away
the other cool thing that you end up
finding out here is the tree is actually
group that's the other thing that you
end up finding out here right like the
tree is grew like when franklin asks
like you know do you think he heard what
i was trying to tell him the tree's just
like i am groot and he's like yeah me
neither
so group basically ends up growing into
a giant tree but what this does is it
basically picks up
51 000 years into the future that that
star brand
and black widow are basically dropped
out from from temporal space so they end
up
back in iron man's workplace and 51 000
years in the future you've basically
just got like this giant planetary space
right with this massive
kind of obelisk you know sitting sitting
you know at a kind of off in the
distance
and captain america is guided towards
this obelisk and then basically
identifies himself right you know he
puts his hand up to the wall uh and then
identifies himself and when he walks in
it's basically told put your hands on
the bars and uh that way we can we can
identify who you are when that happens
of course he's hit with all these you
know prongs and things like that to go
through him and it's just for the
purpose of verifying you know his dna
really just like analyzing his dna and
seeing who he is
and that's when he's met by this massive
world mind and what we end up finding
out here and this is where things get
crazy the requests of the
the cyborg black widow in the ultron
forever universe was fulfilled by
franklin richards that she was basically
given the kind of sentience she wanted
to break off from the larger hole but
what that meant is that as time began to
progress and things began to move
forward that her ai and this this
avengers world began to kind of develop
a sort of sentience and so in effect she
you know a part of ultron
still resides in her and so what it
meant is that in essence ultron more or
less is the world mind now right it's a
giant singular consciousness that exists
inside this world the problem with this
is we don't really find out how
far-reaching it is right we don't really
find out
how far it goes instead all that ends up
happening is this this kind of
artificial intelligence appears to him
as black widow because of the fact that
it's somebody he would recognize along
with these sort of avengers-esque
individuals and states of the intention
here is to basically take the mind of
captain america
upload it into their database scrub it
of anything regarding like individuality
right so captain america's feelings of
righteousness his desire to save
people's lives things like that
that's all going to be removed and he's
going to become part of this kind of
artificial intelligence mind frame
and just exist there his physical body
of course will be destroyed but then a
captain america of course manages to
break free and the idea is that as he's
fighting against these these kind of
holograms there really isn't a whole lot
he can do here right i mean his
shield isn't is the most durable
material in the marvel universe right so
being able to break it is not really a
feasible thing but ultimately this
device
planted inside the mind of of captain
america comes to fruition that what this
was designed to do was basically leap
out of his mind when this artificial
intelligence gave itself a physical form
that it would leap out of the mind of
iron man
and land on this individual right and as
soon as that happened it would start
breaking down the computer core like
it's more or less introducing a virus
into a worldwide computer system and
that's exactly what happens right it
basically shuts down the entire system
it effectively dies and so of course the
the time stone reforms around captain
america
and then whisks him further into the
future or at least kind of sends him
into the time stream and where he seems
to sort of fall down into whatever it is
it would end up taking and presumably
tony stark's lab
he's rescued by iron lad he's basically
rescued by kang the conqueror now kang
is a is a little bit of a confusing
character and we're not going to go
super in depth into him because
it's really overly complicated the long
and short of this
is imagine you went to you time traveled
to
the year 5000 and then you left the year
5000 and went to the year 4000 right but
a
version of you stays in the year 5000.
and let's say that you leave the year
4000 and you go to the year 3000 and a
version of you
stays in the year 4 000. that's what
kane the conqueror is right king of the
conqueror more or less exists in
virtually all time streams but because
of that each one of these quote-unquote
versions of himself
have their own personalities their own
goals their own ambitions different
things like that now
iron lad was part of the young avengers
but i don't really want to go any more
in depth than that because then it
starts getting
wildly confusing but there is some
explanation that's offered here that
where where you have kang you have
iron lad and you have immortus each of
which are basically able to manipulate
the time stream you end up having them
kind of you know making these statements
of things like
the event is coming right like the time
events getting ready to take place which
is basically just the reformation of the
time stone
as soon as that happens as soon as a
time stone begins to reform they use
their power and then basically encase it
in what's called zero time all that
really means is it just nullifies the
time stone that's really all it does
right so it's like it's like if the time
stone was a mutant it would be like
shutting off the mutant's powers right
you know temporarily that's all that is
and it just kind of keeps the time stone
and stasis there and it cannot reform
and yank anybody else through time and
that's when we really start to get this
sort of explanation here we kind of get
this this discussion of what's going on
the idea here is that these guys have
basically brought captain america this
far into the future
because of the fact that the incursions
happen right the incursions are
currently happening the multiverse is
collapsing universes are crashing into
each other they have tried
multiple times right captain america has
been yanked into the future like this
multiple times uh he's not aware of it
but basically it's happened
multiple times and the idea is they've
always tried different approaches
captain america has gone back in time
and destroyed
the illuminati captain america has gone
back in time and worked with the
illuminati captain america has gone back
in time
and reformed a cosmic cube to try to
save the day they've tried all these
different
things and none of them work the
multiverse always moves towards this
inevitable end and it always ends up
collapsing now the question you're
probably asking here is
if the multiverse collapses and
everybody dies then how do they exist in
the future
okay uh jonathan hickman answered this
during the the fantastic four run that
he had and the way this works is it's
not as though
the the incursions take place right like
the main marvel universe is destroyed
and then
everything suddenly ceases to exist it's
almost like a tidal wave so like imagine
a meteor crashing into the earth it's
only the earth just suddenly explodes
right it's not like everything around
the earth just instantly go you know
bursts into flame then instead what you
have is you have this massive
impact and then you have fire that
begins to just sort of spread out that's
how that works when the universe
collapses and
when everything is destroyed that would
happen at some point in the past and
what what that would mean
is uh basically like a tidal wave would
start making its way through the time
stream from the time that that initially
happened going both directions right and
so basically it would move
you know into the past and it would move
into the present and basically make its
way here and so
you know if you had to assign a kind of
time frame to it you could say that like
the main marvel universe earth
crashes into another earth and the main
marvel universe is destroyed when that
initial point of destruction happens
then it would be like
10 minutes before everything's totally
wiped out at that point we're just
throwing out arbitrary numbers but
that's basically what that means right
that's basically how that works and so
that's why they're here is because
technically the multiverse will be
destroyed we're just at that point like
captain america's been transported to
this moment before the future's been
obliterated right so there's still a
chance to kind of save the day that's
why they're here but basically their
their whole response is
every time you go back nothing ever
works and so we're going to do the only
thing we know how to do which is to keep
you
here if we keep you here and we let the
illuminati do their job then they'll
basically destroy
every single incurs of earth and there's
a chance that when that happens that the
main marvel universe will be the only
universe in the entirety of the
multiverse because of the fact that the
heroes were able to do everything they
needed to do in order to save the day
but keep in mind franklin richards you
know kind of talked about this
and said it won't work nothing will work
the multiverse will die
this is what we're talking about when
we're talking about multiple people out
there
trying to find a way to keep the
multiverse from ending that in effect
everybody's wrong right nobody's right
that the multiverse
will actually end we know that right we
know that because that's what we're
being told over and over and over again
that everything is going to die
it's just all anybody can do is the best
they can do to try to stop it as best
they can but captain america being
captain america is kind of interesting
because he hits on this idea that he's
tired of people telling him uh that he
doesn't understand right he's hired
people telling him like we're gonna keep
you here because you don't fully
understand what you're doing he's tired
of hearing that that people kind of look
at him as a guy who never fully
understands the breadth of the decisions
that he's making right that captain
america is more or less a dummy he's
just he follows orders because that's
what he's supposed to do
and he'll prize the lives of innocent
people over everything else because
that's just what he does that in his
mind he doesn't weigh
you know the the the cost of his
decisions well he doesn't really look at
an innocent life that's that's
in jeopardy and then ask the question
what happens if i save that person's
life captain america does what he does
right he's he preserves innocent life as
best he can but despite the case that he
makes that's his problem right captain
america stands up for for righteousness
he stands up for innocent people he
helps people where he can but at the end
of the day he doesn't have the capacity
to understand the full totality of what
he's doing because he's just not that
smart right he's just not that
intelligent doesn't mean he's stupid
it just means that he's not on the same
level as tony stark or reed richards and
where he should stop and think and ask
what's the end result of what i'm doing
at the end of the day he doesn't want to
that's one of the things that was kind
of interesting is that when hawkeye from
48 years in the future
was talking to him that what he said is
when he gets to this point that he's
going to be asked he's going to be told
you only have two choices to make you
know the the choice you're going to have
is to a
you know basically either do nothing or
to help tony stark right to help him
and the other members of the new
avengers destroy you know alternate
realities but the third option is
he could kill tony stark he could
destroy tony stark and that's the option
captain america goes for he basically
grabs the shield throws it has a bounce
off a couple of walls destroy the
barrier around the time stone when it
reforms around him he's teleported back
to the present day he meets with the
rest of the avengers who were here tony
stark is already gone at that point
but he meets with the rest of the
avengers who were here and then
basically tells them we're going to do
what we should have done the entire time
right now that we're aware of what's
going on we're gonna do the only thing
that we that we can do we're tracking
down the new avengers we're gonna track
down every single one of them tony stark
reed richards doctor strange
beast uh black bolt t'challa name of the
submariner we're gonna track them all
down and we're going to take them into
custody we're gonna stop them from doing
what they're doing right at the end of
the day all captain america is really
doing here
is becoming a hassle that where the the
new avengers are doing the right thing
and destroying other realities in order
to save their own captain america is
gonna get in the way of that but that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you